LL RIGHT, MANUTHK MUCH.
AND JOINING ME FIRST
WYOMING O'S ONE OF TWOBLICANS SE
OU THINKAS THE MOST RTANT PART
WELL,, JAKE.
IT'S GOOD TO BE WITH YOUMPORTAN
PART WAS THE OPP THEPLR DIRECTLY
FROM THESE HEROES, THESE MEN W
UGR THEM TO AR FIRST-HAND ACCOU
FOOTAGE THAT WE HADN'T SEE
BEFORESOF EXACTL
PARTICULARLY THOSE ON THWERE FI
THEY UNDERSTOOTHATTHEY MHT.
AND TO HEAR,NO
RIOTERANE IN THE I
TE POLICECERS, YOREDI
TONIGHT.
I THINK THOSE KINDS OF ARE
ARE HELD ACCEOPLWHTHIS CAN NEVEO
>>TODAUO ALSO KNHAT HAPPY MIAT
ERY  UNQUOTEVE C
Y
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE COULD
LEARN?
E NEED TO UNDERSTAND E PLANNINGG
NEED TUNDERSTAND, YOU KNOW
HOW IT WAS THA ENDED PEOPLWHY E
ARE CONDUCTING THI
VIOLENT ASSAULT ON THE CAPITOL.
NNRE.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
ORGANIZATIONALAS.W SOME THINGS ,
OBVIOUSLTTACK
WAS ING,
DID NOT SEND
U LOOK ATHE THINGS THAT WE KF YA
THERE ALREADY.
A T LL
.AND THS REALLY MATTERED THIS A
THFOR E MMLD B.
O NAED?
>> THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
NG TO BE DETNED
WHERE THEACTS.AN TS
BELIEVES THAT
BE I
WE M
ENFORCE OENAS, IF PEOPLE
CHOO TO T THEM
BUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THATE.
IMPORTANT THAT THE
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED AND THAT
AGAIN.
WETO DEMOCRACY. OWET TO OUR
EP OWE IUR
E COMM GO TO COURT
ENFORC NECESSARY
F
IF THEY REFUSE TO  ABSOLUTELY.T
TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS ABOUWHOA
DOCUMENTS WE NEED.
THOSE AR WILL BERMINEDN THE
AND WE HAVE TO BWI GO
TO COUO E THOSE IFHE>> ONE OF GG
OTHERS ARE SAYING THAT T
EIOTHESE  FD TOAL
THE EL ONCE AND
GOING TO TRY AGAIN.
DON'TEAN McCARTHYAND STEVSCE E
WOULD VE TT AGAIN.
THERE ISERO ATTEMPT REASSURING
>> LOOGGESTING ITRUE.
IT'S ACTUALLY EVEN WORSE THAN
TH,
I IN IN A
ER THAT
YOU MENTIONED SEEM TO VIEW THIS
AS SOME RTF A PARTISAN
AND AS AHED SAW THISNIEALLY DEA.
THIS IA ERE THS LD ACLOSE-RUN T.
AND AS THE CHAIRMAN SAID,
DIE UL TRANSFEOF
WE HAD AN  HAD
AND TODAY YOU HAD MEMBERS  RESS
CONGRESS ACTUALLPROTESTING IOF E
F OF THE PEOPL
HERENDN ARRESTED
BECAUSE  PIN THE
INS.S GOING ON, ON ONE END
TON.
ONTHERN CAPITOL
HIE STGYM HO
M
WHMEKES TO BLA. LISTEHIHHE PRES
NGN STEFANIK.
IBHE HOUSE THECCURREONAN
h.
>> IN, THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
SPEAKER PELOSI IS IN HOUSE
MORE THAN THEN MAJERCONNELL WAS.
WHAT'S YOUR RETI TI
FOR AN ISPED IN
THINGS, JAKE.WOULD SAY APLE
NUMBER O, THIS COMMITTEE
GOING TO ITI
ASPECT O HAPPENED.
THE PL, THE FINANCING, THE
PREPIO THE
WHAT WAS HAPPENING THAT DAY IN
THE WHITE HOUSE, WHAT WAS
ENING HERE APITOL,
THE SECURITY BREACHES AT THECAP
WE AREN'T GOING TO BNG
A COMPLETE INVESTIGATION I
ER TWO, IF I WERE SAYING THE
PYED,
WHAT HAP ABSOLUTEL
WD THIS INTOLERABLCRUELTY.
A B THAT WAS ASSEMBLED BP, WASRA
WET JUST IN THE
SPEECHE LI
TS COMMITTEE NEEDS TOUNDERSTANE
THE PLANNINGTHG.
R TIATEH H
SHOU DIDN'T KNOWAKER
PELOLLOR
TH
YOU ARE  CONSERVATIVE E'
PROGRESSIVDE.
YOU'RE BOTH FAIRLY PARN.
ATIKIN
>> YOU KNOW, I'VE Y
IMPRES
PROFESSIONALISM AND THE ITMENTOS
I THK U KNOW, AS
MOMENT THAT HA BE ABOVE
E WE ALL
TO SAY TO OUS ARWER OATH, GOINGP
GODOWN A
PATH THA
WILLING TOO, AND I THINK IT'S '
CRUCIAL FOR THE COUNTRY THAT
HEARING, ONE OF THFOUR
THE COMMITTEE CONGRESSMAAMINGER.
TAKE LAMBEINUS
HE.AND WHILE I AGRE THEY TOLD
THE TRUTH?
TIS.S T HAR
>> WHAT WEREOUWHEN
HE SAID THAT?
HINKING THAT HARRY AND
THE OTR OFFICERS TEY E THE HERO
LIKELY OURF EY ARE
AND DEFENDED THI
AND THAT AS ELECTED OFFICIALS,
SITTINGI S ED THAT O
ELVES IN WAY T WORTHHE SACRIFICY
MADE AND THEIR WIL
THEY BELIEVE THEY MIGHT DI
GONELLL SAD, I
HT, BUT THAT IS SOMETHI E TO FAN
ORDER TO DEFENL
ALCONDUCELVES INY THAT IWOEM AND
WORTHY OF THE REPUBLIC THAT WE
HAVE SSTITUTION THAT
WE
>>SOME OF YOUR
BEHIND THE SCENES.UES ARE G ONEQ
SAYING BEHIND THE SCENES?
>> YOU KNO I THINK WE'VE SEEN
CONCERN AMONG, YOUNOW, A
ERF REPUBLICANS THAT PUBLICHER,
KNOW, REAL SECURITY THREATS.ANS
E WILLAY THAT THEYRECOGNAN
NECESSITY OF THE TRUTH ANDHENEC
NOT TO DRAW THE WRAT
FO, FRANKLY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY SAID YESTERDAY THATCOM
QUOTE/UNQU
REPUBLICE E HE
A LOT MORE THAN U
DO.
W E TH
BLAT A
GITIGATION?L, TODAY A TART.
BROADCASTING OF E TESTIMONY OF
E WITNESSES ING TO
HET THS OUT IS
REALLY IOR.
AND THATHETHIS
PROCESS.THINK THATR McCARTND
ERN OBLIGATION
TORUSOME OF US FEEL LIKEYO,  OU.
I THINK LEADERIS CONTINUING TO
HE VIEWS THIS E F A
IT'S NOT